[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
dans sa bourgade émission un peu
particulière ce soir l'assemblée
nationale a rendu hommage à samuel pâtit
ce professeur d'histoire sauvagement
assassinée cérémonie exceptionnelle on
en reverra les images suivie d'une
séance de questions au gouvernement
électrique l'union sacrée vole en éclats
pourquoi on s'interrogera on va leur a
aussi dû sieverts islamisme comment
lutter contre les propagateurs de haine
sur les réseaux sociaux ceux qui ont
jeté en pâture le nom de samuel pâtit
sur internet manif ya pas à convoquer
toutes les plateformes place beauvau et
pour commenter tous ces sujets un ancien
président de l'assemblée nationale il ne
s'est pas encore exprimé sur cet
attentat effroyable
jean louis debré et notre grand témoin
ce soir voilà donc pour le programme
c'est parti à chaque cvr pour réagir sur
twitter
[Musique]
bonsoir jean loup devrait merci
infiniment d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes chez vous si j'ose
dire dans cette maison le palais bourbon
ancien président de l'assemblée
nationale ancien président du conseil
constitutionnel on va revenir sur
l'hommage de la représentation nationale
aujourd'hui vous y étiez tous les trois
messieurs les députés hommage évidemment
au professeur samuel pâtit bonsoir
francis choix franchement merci d'être
là vous êtes député la république en
marche de l'essonne proche de manuel
valls auquel vous avez succédé dans sa
circonscription d'evry bienvenue sur ce
plateau eric diard merci d'être là
députée les républicains des bouches du
rhône auteur avec le journaliste henri
vernet d'une enquête sur la
radicalisation dans les services publics
ce que l'on ne vous dis pas cette aux
éditions lattès et c'est la prolongation
du rapport parlementaire que vous aviez
signé à l'assemblée enfin bienvenue
avoue fabien roussel seront soir
secrétaire nationale du parti communiste
et député pc du nord fait richard
ferrand qui a pris l'initiative
aujourd'hui pour rendre hommage à ce
professeur samuel pâtit une cérémonie a
été organisée devant la place de la
concorde derrière les colonnes les
écharpes tricolores la représentation
nationale images compilé pour vous par
maïté frémont regarder
on
mesdames messieurs les présidents des
groupes politiques de l'assemblée
nationale mesdames messieurs les députés
mesdames messieurs je vous invite à un
moment de recueillement en mémoire le
professeur samuel pâtit sauvagement
assassinée
[Musique]
artois
dans le respect de l'état de droit
soyons lucides ces terroristes
quand ils sont français qu'ils soient
punis et banni de la société jusqu'à
leur conversion sincère aux valeurs
démocratiques
quand ils sont étrangers qu'ils soient
chasser à jamais des territoires de la
république
il intègre en ils ne tiendront jamais la
voix de la liberté
ils ne tiendront jamais les lumières de
la connaissance qui répandent l'esprit
républicain et forment des citoyens
l'assemblée nationale n'oubliera jamais
votre nom et le crime qui vous avez ôté
la vie
monsieur le professeur en mémoire de
monsieur samuel pâtit je vous invite à
observer une minute de silence
voilà donc pour les temps forts de ces
hommages on va revenir sur toutes ces
images on voudrait mais d'abord vous ne
voudrez pas exprimé sur le sujet qu'avez
vous ressenti vendredi soir en apprenant
qu'un professeur d'histoire avait été
décapité pour avoir enseigné la liberté
d'expression dans sa classe pour moi ça
a été un moment de communion dans notre
histoire de d'une très grande tristesse
pourquoi parce que c'était les
fondements de ce qui nous rassemble qui
était tout d'un coup décapité ce qui
nous rassemble c'est naturellement la
liberté mais il n'y a pas de liberté
sans égalité et il n'y a pas de
fraternité sans égalité et il n'y a pas
de liberté d'égalité et de fraternité
sont la laïcité
or le combat de la france pour la
laïcité est un combat qui a été
difficile mais ce qui nous permet de
vivre ensemble
c'est cette laïcité or tout d'un coup on
assassinait un homme un professeur qui
est là pour éduquer nos enfants pour
éduquer les vraies valeurs on l'est on
assassiner un professeur qui avait
enseigné ce qui est au coeur de la
république la liberté et la direction
comme sous le choc
ils attendent évidemment au delà des
discours et des hommages des actes est
ce que est ce qu'on est à un moment de
bascule dans la prise de conscience est
ce que c'en est fini du déni de liste m
israël ne sais pas ce que j'ai aimé dans
cette photo sur le perron c'est que face
à de tels accidents ni aux bleus l'unité
nationale la cohésion nationale essayons
un instant de faire oublier les
critiques elles viendront en france on
aime beaucoup critiqué mais la seule
réponse à celles et ceux qui ne croient
pas en la république c'est de montrer
que les élus de la nation quelle que
soit leur appartenance est ce qu'elle
était sincère cette image eric diard on
verra ce qui s'est passé un peu plus
tard aux questions au gouvernement
oui c'était le moment de recueillement j
étais l'image était sincère après dans
les questions au gouvernement ce qui
s'est passé je pense que il ya eu un peu
des échanges peut-être à mon avis le
premier ministre a manqué un petit peu
de deux d'humilité petit peu et après il
fallait pas s'énerver pour autant je
pense faire et montrer ce qui s'est
passé parce que il y a les images les
écharpes le recueillement la minute de
silence et puis à peine une demi heure
plus tard après sept minutes monsieur
debré regardez ce qui s'est passé dans
les musiques la dure là les heures à
venir
c'est que ça moment de recueillement
mais pour moi c'est aussi la grande
espérance espérance que la
représentation nationale arrivera un
moment à faire tenir alors est-ce
qu'elle sera la hauteur regardez ce qui
s'est passé dans l'hémicycle et je vous
fait réagir juste après du chu et
voilà ces images où on les connaît un
les mardis après midi l'opposition dans
son rôle voilà utilise utilisent cette
épître est ce que c'était vraiment le
bon dieu pour faire ça à votre avis
fabien roussel
écoutez je pense que on est encore dans
l'émotion en tout cas quand je revois
mois les images où on est tous ensemble
devant l'assemblée nationale
je voyais tout à l'heure les images de
la marche blanche à conflans jeu
je suis encore choqué par ce qui s'est
passé parce que effectivement quand on
s'attaque un professeur avec une volonté
délibérée de tuer au nom de l'islam
politique radicale assumer affirmé
relayée par d'autres
c'est extrêmement grave et il faut le
mesurer et prendre le temps de le
mesurer
c'est pour ça que voilà capitation c'est
sa maison qu'il faut il faut pouvoir
mesurer sa se dire qu' on ne peut pas le
minimiser
se dire qu' on ne peut plus dire qu'on
ne savait pas c'est prendre la mesure du
défi qui est en face de nous et est
peut-être un moment donné se poser et se
dire bon maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on fait
la situation est extrêmement grave des
réponses du gouvernement on va y venir
des propositions de l'opposition
française soit je vais vous montrer une
autre image
il ya exactement cinq ans c'est juste
après les attentats de charlie hebdo et
de l'hyper cacher ce jour là on est les
regarder le 13 le 15 janvier
pardonnez-moi en 2015
écoutez
on est ravi
sans bandés
[Musique]
voilà et vous savez que ce jour là c'est
à cinq ans d'un député à l'ère serge
grouard député de l'opposition à
l'époque qui lance cette marseillaise
qui crépite dans l'hémicycle ça c'est
l'union nationale pourquoi on n'y arrive
pas aujourd'hui j'ai un souvenir
particulier sur ce qui s'est passé et au
cours de la déclaration de politique
générale du premier ministre de l'époque
puisque l'assemblée s'est levé à
plusieurs reprises dans une unanimité
totale et par cette initiative d'un
député l'opposition à l'époque et tout
le monde entonne la marseillaise j'étais
devant la télévision dans bureau de
maire de la ville d'evry courcouronnes
j'en avais les larmes aux yeux c'est
j'en ai reparlé très récemment avec
manuel valls je veux et par rapport à
aujourd'hui moi ce que je veux retenir
des unions c'est la désunion qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui on sera prêt après les les
écharpes tricolores ce que je veux
retenir c'est les images que vous venez
de repasser la première fois je me
retrouvais devant les colonnes de
l'assemblée nationale face à la concorde
et à la scène c'est la première fois que
je me retrouvais je peux aussi mes
collègues s'étaient déjà retrouvés avec
la garde républicaine
et puis je veux surtout retenir les
propos la déclaration extraordinaire du
président de l'assemblée nationale et je
pense j'imagine comme mes collègues
comme le président de bris qu'il aurait
fallu rester sur cette trajectoire du
président de l'assemblée nationale parce
qu'il a bu il a mis les mots où il
fallait il admet même chose avec la
seule la même impatience
il ya une forme de lassitude aussi dans
le pays tout entier on le voyait à la
marche ont jamais juger les gens
attendent déjà je voulais pourquoi
j'étais vous planche d'autant plus
sensibles c'est que pas plus tard
qu'hier comme beaucoup d'autres est
encore bien plus que place de la
république dimanche était plutôt convenu
c'est les centaines de personnes qui
sont pour la septième fois la septième
fois retrouvés sur la place des droits
de l'homme et du citoyen à evry co
couronne avec beaucoup d'enseignants
pourtant en vacances et où beaucoup me
disent et monsieur le maire aux députés
mais ça va s'arrêter quand et comment
vous pouvez gravité du moment comment
vous pouvez nous dire que alors cette
fois ci ça l'est resté dans cette fois
ci ça ne se reproduira pas fait ce qu'on
entend à chaque fois il ya des mesures
qui ont été prises depuis vendredi
depuis vendredi soir il ya des mesures
qui ont été prises d'ailleurs elles sont
un peu égrainé chaque jour vous allez
réagir eric diard on va écouter
aurore bergé en colère aurore bergé
votre collègue de la majorité
elle parle du du déni qui a duré trop
longtemps elle considère que le
gouvernement avance face au concours
lépine du référendum je préfère
l'expulsion des étrangers radicaliser et
la dissolution des associations qui
professent la haine de la république
vous l'avez dit vous l'avez dit nous
sommes en guerre alors madame la
ministre
comment garantir aux français que nous
allons unis avec tous les serviteurs de
la république nous donner les moyens de
gagner cette guerre
voilà eric diard depuis vendredi et
toute une série de mesures qui ont été
annoncées
encore aujourd'hui le président de la
république vient d'en faire à bobigny
qu'est ce qu'il décide de dissoudre le
collectif cheikh yacine on va l'écouter
tout tout de suite mais regardez vous a
préparé la liste de cent trente et une
personnes étrangères en situation
irrégulière fichiers pour radicalisation
vont être expulsés dissolutions
d'associations parle d'une liste de 50
associations dont le ccf baraka city
fermeture pour six mois de la mosquée de
pantin 34 opération de police au sein de
la mouvance islamiste
des interpellations également
d'internautes qui ont fait l'apologie de
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit c'est un
pas en avant
vous le reconnaissez ça me peine avant
mais c'est ce n'est pas suffisant si
vous le savez très bien comment cela
marche
les 231 expulsés dans une année ne
seront pas expulsés
iliad est en cours parce qu'il ya des
recours parce qu'il ya des personnes
il ya des états qui ne veulent plus
l'algérie le maroc ne veut plus distant
des terroristes on ne les veut plus dans
notre pays il ya un système de du
tribunal adminstratif qui est très long
donc si on au raccourci passé délai si
on va être on va sur une grosse
déception on n'aura pas d'anonymisation
sur les réseaux sociaux
donc il ya quand même un gros problème
il ya eu des efforts qui ont été faits
mois parlant de son éducation nationale
maintenant il ya des référents
radicalisation l'information remonte
mais par contre les atteintes à la
laïcité
le prosélytisme ça ne remonte pas les
professeurs ne sont pas assez soutenu
donc il y à faire des gestes mais c'est
insuffisant mais bien sûr on en arrivera
pas éradiquer le problème on a trop de
retard et bien vous savez ces mesures
vous qui représentez les communistes
vous vous les soutenez toutes ne seront
pas des mesures législatives
mais oui enfin je veux dire il ya des
mesures à prendre dès aujourd'hui pour
condamner d'année poursuivre les auteurs
mais ceux qui ont participé
indirectement ceux qui ont relayé les
messages il faut que ça ne peut pas se
reproduire que le message soit bien
passé pour tout le monde ici sur ceux
qui utilisent les réseaux sociaux c'est
que ceux qui ont envie de relayer ou de
liker ce type de message qu'il ce qu'ils
se disent qu'ils peuvent être pris
demain et être poursuivi par la justice
donc il ya des mesures de court terme de
sanction ou la justice doit faire son
travail et on doit comprendre ce qui
s'est passé parce que ça sert aussi à ça
la justice et de comprendre et à des
mesures de plus long terme de de donner
les moyens à notre éducation nationale
de pouvoir faire ce travail auprès de
nos enfants où il ya tant à faire on
sait que nous avons aujourd'hui des
enfants français des jeunes qui se
radicalise et qu'ils sont français ils
cheikh de qui mais c'est l'échec c'est
l'échec ces individus là sont des années
d'échecs de retard qu'il faut mesurer
est justement là où la république la
république a reculé
il faut aujourd'hui la ré instaurer des
regards et ça ça va prendre du temps
d'années ce regard pourquoi ces mesures
c'est la question pourquoi abdel abdel
hakim sefrioui le prédicateur islamiste
impliqués dans cette affaire n'a pas été
expulsé
pourquoi on expulse maintenant deux cent
trente et une personnes alors qu'on
pouvait le faire avant abdelhakim
sefrioui des années on le connaît il
habitait brico prône le leader de baraka
city que le leader de baraka six tickets
l'on présente absolument insulte pour
les ong comme une ong mais qui est en
véritable en vérité une véritable
officines seul assistant lien d'ailleurs
avec le ccf est en lien et voilà j'ai
retrouvé ce qu'il ya quelques mois ce
fameux idrissi abidi qui c'est qui s'est
lancé dans une bulle harcèlement précise
raoui le président il ya un an à tout
c'est à toutes ces saletés de médias
c'est sur twitter à toutes ces saletés
de médias et de politique mais aussi
d'élus qui ont nourri l'islamophobie
voilà le maître mot du ccf j'en attends
je termine aux extrêmes on ne vous
lâchera plus en redoublera d'intensité
pour enterrer à jamais votre aide des
musulmans et faire de votre vie un enfer
sur terre
baraka city donc ça fait des années que
comme maire je suis sur le coup avec eux
depuis 2010 est comme avant 2000 la
dissolution d'une association c'est un
conseil des ministres une décision qui
sera prise d'ailleurs demain il ya des
conseils des miss tous les mercredis
avec des avocats qui sont
enfin avec barak a city bardet d'avocats
avec toute une série de problèmes liés
aux conditions de réalisation donc moi
je me félicite de ces mesures
mais là où je rejoins sans doute le
sentiment général c'est qu'il faut que
ces mesures rapides ne soit surtout pas
des mesures fugace parce que le problème
n'est pas de passer le temps de
l'émotion pour ensuite refaire une
petite gâterie de long terme venice le
déni de la laïcité la république négocie
au rendez compte que depuis des années
dans les établissements scolaires la
république se négocie et bien dire qu'il
ne peut plus avoir de république qui se
négocie la république on convint la
république
on l'a on la fait vivre alors aucune des
inégalités sociales territoire mais la
république ne se négocie pas elle pense
on va avancer là c'est un tournant qui a
été opéré je devrai tout de suite et
j'espère que ça va continuer pour juste
vous faire entendre le chef de l'état
nouvelle mesure je vous le disais
annoncée à bobigny et je vous redonne la
parole tout avons tout de suite après
dès demain en conseil des ministres nous
aurons à dissoudre le groupement de fait
chez kia cee'd directement impliqués
dans l'attentât
des décisions de ce type à l'encontre d'
association de groupement d'individus
suivront dans les prochains jours et des
prochaines semaines
notre détermination est entière
les actes seront là
la république on a besoin voilà les
actes seront là la république en a
besoin on entend ces mots à chaque fois
là on voit qu'il y a un début de 1 des
bus d'action jean louis debré ya deux
choses d'abord dans ce que nous vivons
il ya deux séquences et la séquence de
cet après midi j'étais devant mon poste
de télévision et j'ai souffert et j'ai
souffert de voir la représentation
nationale quitter son unité nationale
pour donner le sentiment
il faut faire ça donc quand vous
l'expliquer je n'estime pas jeu
je sais pas simplement une fois
sarrasine face aux terroristes
c'est face à celles et ceux qui veulent
tuer la république tu es la laïcité
il ya une réponse c'est de montrer notre
dignité de montrer notre détermination
tous ensemble ça c'est urgent
deuxièmement naturellement que le temps
du bilan viendra et que le temps des
mesures viendront mais parmi ces
patients puissent depuis 30 ans ça je
vous rappelle les débats qu'il ya eu sur
le port du voile à l'école je présidais
la commission dans cette maison et on
était arrivé à la suite d'une commission
où tout le monde y est représenté à ce
ver voter la loi la commission stasi
oui non la commission stasi c'est une
commission qui a été voulu par le
président l'a public
nous nous avions fait une commission à
l'assemblée nationale avec tous les
représentants des partis politiques
l'internet et la loi a été votée à
l'unanimité sauf une voix montrant ainsi
à celles et ceux qui voulaient porter
atteinte à la laïcité que
l'argumentation nationale toutes
tendances confondues
alors aujourd'hui on a eu des critiques
certains critiques portaient sur des
mesures d'application le problème n'est
pas la loi
ce sont les mesures d'application et
l'état de droit et a le droit même nous
avons nous avons dans la constitution
tout dans les principes constitutionnels
la république est une république laïque
le qui condamne le séparatisme
appliquons la loi
vous répondez simplement monsieur
président qu'est ce que vous répondez
quand eric diard vous dit on a un
problème d'exécution des décisions qui
sont des décisions législatives qui
peuvent être des décisions de règlement
quand vous avez une expulsion qu'elle
n'est pas suivi d'effet le drame
aujourd'hui
c'est laid back droit fois vous l'avez
bien connus comme président du conseil
constitionnel des recommandations plus
qu'obligatoire du conseil constitionnel
qui parfois nous l'assuré est
aujourd'hui imitée
ce qu'il faudrait pas tomber c'est dans
la loi objet de communication politique
or très souvent pour se dédouaner
on fait des lois je suis un exemple
quand je suis arrivée au conseil
constitionnel ont été saisis d'une loi
sur la lutte contre l'immigration
illégale
c'était la troisième loi et les décrets
d'application des deux précédentes
étaient encore pc bah ouais donc je
voulais attention les conditions là les
lois trop de lois tuent la loi moi là je
vais défiler un petit peu de mots
différencier du du président du conseil
constitionnel moi ce qui m'ennuie dans
l'ariège vous l'avez été quand même je
ne veux pas changer la constitution mais
ya quand même un problème dans cette
constitution la laïcité elle l article
une la france est une république une
indivisible social démocrate etc
mais vous avez en face la liberté
religieuse et donc dons à travers la
constitution la problématique c'est que
la laïcité pour moi n'a pas de force
exécutoire sujet très important parce
que parce que c'est au coeur du débat
est-ce que contre l'islamisme l'état de
droit est adapté je vous fais rencontre
entendre le patron des républicains
damien abad qui explique qu'au fond tous
ces textes proposés dans l'opposition
ont été rejetées principe majoritaire
oblige mais qu'il faut changer la
constitution
ecoutez-le vous réagir après j'ai pas
dit ça expulsé de notre territoire
national et étranger fiché pour
radicalisation et terrorisme refusé
fermé laissant mosquées salafistes et
les salles de prière radicaliser refusé
expulser les imams radicaliser refusé
réduire l'immigration grâce à une
restriction du regroupement familial du
droit d'asile et du droit du sol refusé
interdire les listes communautariste aux
élections refusez rendre obligatoires
les examens radiologiques aussi pour
bénéficier du statut de mineur non
accompagné refusèrent interdire le
retour des djihadistes sur le territoire
national refuse et interdire de tout
emploi public les personnes radicaliser
refuser encore monsieur le premier
ministre si nous voulons ensemble qu'ils
ne passent plus il est temps de passer
des paroles aux actes
et pour cela si nous devons modifier la
constitution alors faisons le et
modifions la cessoie vous lever les yeux
au ciel
pourquoi ai je lève les yeux au ciel
d'abord parce que modifier la
constitution pense que sur la forme je
trouve ce tels ceux d'asie bao
d'objectifs qui ne sont pas atteintes
sont pas à la hauteur et deuxièmement
alors il se contredit lui-même parce que
c'est surtout pas par un très long
processus de révision de la constitution
qu'on va répondre
la liste des courses cet accord de loi
organique papa un changement
considérable
je vais juste me déchire on pas sûr
qu'ils vont donner le sentiment aux
françaises et aux français que les
politiques s'intéressent à autre chose
et il y as tout juridique on peut faire
une loi organique
tous dans notre loi dans notre
constitution qui permet de lutter contre
l'islamisme radical
refuser beaucoup ne sont pas des nommés
il existe aujourd'hui l'outil pour
lutter contre les messages haineux sur
internet avec far aux cette plateforme
incendiée par dix mois un moyen de 2 200
fort mais elles existent il faut de lui
donner les moyens non seulement de
surveiller de censurer et ensuite de
protéger ceux qui sont menacés alors les
moyens existants je vous posais la
question autres années on a une école de
la république qui existe qui existe qui
est forte qui a été affaiblie on a
besoin de soutenir nos professeurs hélas
aujourd'hui ils ont besoin
ne pas être 30 par classe quand c'est si
difficile d'enseigner certaines matières
et certains sujets et bien confortons
les deux et faisons celle ci a plus de
moyens dans l'éducation nationale on
ferait reculer de beny 6e
il était plus à l'aise s'il avait eu
quinze élèves au lieu de 30 pour aborder
des sujets compliqués mairie vous voulez
mais dans lesquels l'islamisme effort
n'a alors que les services du ministre
on l'a alors qu'il ya et on nous vend
pas beaucoup de moyens les professeurs
nous disent que ça fait des années
qu'ils tirent la sonnette d'alarmé qu'il
est difficile d'aborder des sujets tels
que la shoah le conflit israélo
palestinien
la liberté d'expression les caricatures
depuis que c'est au programme
ils disent que ça suscite et des débats
et des tensions et avec les élèves et
avec les parents pourquoi on les laisse
encore avec 30 35 élèves par classe et
donc avoir beaucoup d'élèves à gérer et
parfois avec violence
ils devraient la question je sais comme
c'est comme nous aident nos infirmiers
face au virus enfin je veux dire parfois
il ya un moment donné il faut le mal et
oui voilà je vais vous dire pourquoi le
mal est profond
je rappelle quand même un sondage ifop
de 2018 38% des enseignants se sont vus
chahutée pour les ce qu'il ya dans le
court 58 % en zone prioritaire 37 % des
enseignants eux ce ce sens sur 57 % dans
les zones prioritaires
le mal est plus profond il faut
impérativement mon avis que le
prosélytisme et les atteintes à la
laïcité avec des circonstances
aggravantes soit des infractions
caractérisées
il fait l'école de la république ne doit
plus accepter cela monsieur le député la
laïcité c'est la liberté
cg et donc la liste est garanti à chacun
et à chacune de choisir la religion de
son choix de croire ou de ne pas qu'on
pas croire bien il a causé ces droits
garantis et c'est pas ça qui est en
cause là c'est pas cette liberté qui est
en cause ce qui est en cause c'est ce
qui porte atteinte à cette liberté est
donc atteinte à la laïcité eholié et
ont des moyens à la fois policiers
d'investigation pour l'éducation
nationale pour permettre aux hussards de
la république qui porte la laïcité de
diffuser ses idées
voilà donc attention impact ou modifier
donnons à notre administration
comme on est arrivé à le faire dans
d'autres administrations co éducation
nationale à faire en sorte qu' il n'y
ait pas de signes ostentatoires et de
dates à reporter aux principes sur la
liberté
est-ce que ça n'est qu'une question de
moyens
ah non je pense que c'est toujours une
question moyens c'est évident moyens
sanctions c'est évident que dans
l'éducation nationale y ait des progrès
qui ont été faits en particulier depuis
trois ans je les vois comme ancien maire
d evry courcouronnes dans les 55 écoles
de la ville mais c'est vrai qu'il s'est
toujours passionné suffisante la lutte
contre les inégalités sociales et
territoriales est un combat permanent
j'aurais personnellement préféré qu'on
mette en oeuvre les dispositions du plan
borloo plutôt que de procrastiner autour
de lui d'accord mais il est évident mais
je pense l'abondance des moyens ne
ratent leur aide le rapace que mes
collègues ont dit que ce soit à 30 par
classe c'est trop où ça soit à 15 ou 20
comme dans dans ma ville
la contestation des cours le fait que la
république soit aujourd'hui une sorte de
marchandise que l'on discute en fonction
de ceci ou de cela c'est pas maintenant
il ya une loi qui est annoncé moi
j'avais pas forcément prévu qu'il y ait
une loi quand j'avais travaillé sur le
sujet qu'elle s'appelle de manière
traite les rois j'ai une proposition
politique que je fais en mon nom
personnel pas au nom de mon groupe et
que je fais puisque je vous sais que si
on veut effectivement travaillé sur ces
questions dans un dans un esprit de
concorde dans un esprit de rassemblement
plaire parce que les rassemblements qui
sont pas dans la clarté ça donne du
mélenchon
cette chaîne une commission spéciale qui
viennent travailler la loi de telle
sorte que on arrive à coups
truire le consensus républicain qui
donnera la force du lycée c'est à ces
lois à travers le contrôle du
financement d'un certain nombre
d'associations au niveau préfectoral
comme au niveau de l'état on peut faire
un contrôle de légalité
or les associations ou les sociétés tout
ce que vous voulez qu'ils ne respectent
pas le principe de la laïcité ne doit
pas recevoir de subventions
c'est prévu dans le tamis départ
formation il faut modifier la loi la
possibilité
le métro est nourrie aux 6es ont retiré
les yeux montée du taux n'excédant
contrôle de la légalité
le contrôle de la légalité quand vous
avez une délibération d'un conseil
municipal qui n'est pas conforme
et bien c'est fait pour refuser pour
refuser tout cas je voudrais revenir au
débat qui monte dans le pays dans
l'opposition sur sur l'état de droit ya
eu un texte à l'assemblée nationale une
proposition de loi de la majorité
c'était madame brawn peavey qui la
portait sur le suivi des personnes qui
sortaient de prison des détenus mesure
cette raison mesures de sûreté en contre
deux pour les individus radicalisés ou
pour ceux qui étaient condamnées pour
terrorisme proposition de loi qui a été
adopté là on est sur la loi à
l'assemblée nationale du député je crois
en veillant à l'unanimité et le conseil
constitutionnel la censure et on va
écouter eric ciotti et vous réagissez
juste après nous avions ici voté à la
quasi-unanimité une loi la loi brawn
privé permettant de mieux surveiller les
deux mille cinq cent quarante deux mille
cinq cent quarante détenus islamistes
sorti de prison depuis 2018 ou qui vont
sortir d'ici 2022
le conseil constitutionnel dans une
incroyable naïveté irresponsable est
coupable la censure est mentionné que
vous êtes comment ils réels ne commente
pas les décisions du conseil
constitutionnel se seraient pas bien
simplement il faut après la peine qui a
été exécutée que la privation de liberté
soit décidée page
c'est ça le problème en france on l'a eu
à d'autres moments
or si vous avez des gens qui exécutent
leur peine et que l'administration les
prive de liberté
il ya un problème de droit en fait la
caisse simplement dans cette guerre on
peut faire ce tri nations
quand on rédige des textes à faire en
sorte que le principe absolu de la
liberté de la république à savoir que la
privation de liberté est le fait du juge
et non pas de l'administration
eh bien on peut très bien dans un
article disant aussi un problème
mills tension saisi le juge le partage
quand même la vie je pense que cette loi
est un peu celle été timide mais elle
était mal ficelé puisque ce sarkozy nous
avons fait une loi de rétention de
sûreté et elle a été validée par le
conseil constitutionnel à vous avez une
loi mesures de sûreté à l'encontre des
auteurs face aux terroristes et elle a
été censuré parce que je pense qu'elle a
mal été ficelé pour terminer elle
prendra combien de temps cette bataille
contre l'islamisme politique des années
général
aujourd'hui on a une mesure par jour
qu'on essaye de de comprendre de
commenter c'est le début et il va
falloir du daily mail dès le début de la
bataille
il va falloir assécher le terreau sur
lequel poussent dans notre pays
le terrorisme islamique il va falloir à
sécher ce terreau et ce terreau ils se
trouvent dans des zones de notre
république des ghettos des zones de
non-droit des endroits où il ya parfois
50 % de chômage chez les jeunes où se
concentrent des populations ou je ne
sais pas qui quoi comment mais alors on
fait tout pour les concentrer dans ces
territoires là ça n'excuse en rien
jamais ces crimes seront excusable ça ne
les excuse en rien mais c'est ce terreau
là auxquels il faut s'attaquer
parce que c'est dans ces endroits là que
la république a reculé et qu'il faut la
rétablir
merci beaucoup c'est la sphère d'une
génération d emmanuel valls vous êtes
d'accord d'un mot pour conclure
malheureusement oui mais il faut être
lucide mais il faut surtout pas que ça
conduisent à l'idée qu'on peut plus rien
faire au contraire mais il faut être
lucide on a pris tellement de retard il
ya eu tellement de délits
ils tellement de renoncement la
république est dos au mur depuis
tellement longtemps que et quand je vois
la réaction des jeunes
ça va être long allez et parce que c'est
long c'est absolument indispensable si
sorti du déni je pense qu'ils se
trompent ou manuelle accord pour cela
mais la réponse prendre à prendre du
temps les résultats prendront du temps
merci messieurs vous restez avec nous
jean louis debré on va s'intéresser à
présent à la question des réseaux
sociaux on en parlait avec fabien
roussel
après cet attentat odieux odieux les
plateformes sont au banc des accusés
c'est notre décryptage de suite voilà
elle est devenue un fléau cette haine en
ligne nourrit le passage à l'acte
terroriste la députée laetitia via qui
va nous rejoindre dans un instant résumé
les enjeux de cette bataille lors des
questions au gouvernement écoute et là
elle nous rejoint juste après des vidéos
ont été publiées sur facebook faisant de
ce énième patine cible parce que c'est
ainsi que fonctionnent les réseaux
sociaux pour nuire à quelqu'un il suffit
de les utiliser et de relayer une
revendication sur tweets sur twitter
avec des images abominables à l'appui
des images que l'on peut encore
retrouvées sur certains sites
puis enfin et surtout parce que nous
savons que c'est aussi à travers
internet et les réseaux sociaux que
croit le radicalisme ce qui ce qui était
censé des lieux d'ouverture de
communication de partage deviennent
aussi des vecteurs de diffusion de
l'obscurantisme et des actes terroristes
il se transforme en un lieu où la
liberté d'expression chaque jour éprouvé
de peur d'en subir des conséquences
alors oui il faut réguler les réseaux
sociaux pour qu'ils soient à la hauteur
de leurs promesses initiales pour qu'il
mette en oeuvre tous les moyens
nécessaires pour lutter contre ces
dérives pour qu'ils soient
responsabilisées autour d'un socle
commun de règles il faut ensuite que les
pouvoirs publics soit au rendez vous
pour lutter contre chacun de ceux qui
déversent cette haine
il faut les identifier les poursuivre et
les sanctionner
voilà laetitia bien c'est vous vaut donc
qui pose y est tous les enjeux de cette
lutte contre la haine en ligne que vous
avez porté déjà dans l'hémicycle bonsoir
vous êtes député la république en marche
de paris votre loi
été retoquée par le conseil
constitutionnel en juin dernier et vous
revenez avec une nouvelle mouture si
l'on peut dire loi avia 2 qui serait
compatible avec l'état de droit on va en
parler dans un instant bienvenue sur ce
plateau
gilles babinet bon soit vous êtes
entrepreneur dans l'économie numérique
est conseillé l'institut montaigne sur
ces mêmes questions frédéric reiss
député les républicains du bas rhin va
nous rejoindre dans un instant et
bonsoir stephen bonsoir montréal brenda
cofsky qui nous plante le décor à sa
manière comme tous les soirs dans ce
sujet ô combien complexe si j'ai bien
compris tout de suite si j'ai bien
compris la haine en ligne les fans
j'ai bien compris bien on a enfin
identifié le principal responsable de la
propagation de l'islam radical en france
en fait ils sont plusieurs
ce sont les réseaux sociaux en tout cas
c'est ce que disait ce matin marlène
schiappa sur rtl mais cette idéologie
islamiste comment elle se propage
aujourd'hui elle se propage beaucoup sur
les réseaux sociaux vous avez toute une
génération de jeunes qui se sont pas
radicaliser en allant dans une mosquée
radicaliser où on sent une rencontre ou
en allant en prison
ils se sont radicalisées chez eux tout
seuls dans leur chambre devant un écran
de téléphone ou devant un écran
d'ordinateur donc oui il ya un moyen il
ya un média et semi dias et les réseaux
sociaux
alors c'est pas vraiment nouveau un rôle
des réseaux sociaux dans la diffusion
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que ces
deux remarques et pata pas vraiment
nouvelles seraient des années qu'on met
en en pointe du doigt internet dans la
propagation de l'islam radical
je veux et pris un exemple en 2015 par
exemple après l'attentât du bataclan
xavier bertrand avait réagi en dénonçant
donc internet en prie l'avez compris
cette expression il faut faire attention
à l'imam google loyers y avait un
article dans le monde qui reprenait sept
cette formule je me rappelle qu'à
l'époque gérald darmanin était son
directeur de campagne on est exactement
sur la même longueur d'onde mais voilà
cinq ans plus tard après donc le crime
l'assassinât de ça mais le bâti c'est
exactement les mêmes formules le même
xavier bertrand emploi exactement le
même terme pour dénoncer la même chose
attention cette fameuse qu'imam google
sous-entendu la puissance des réseaux
sociaux et dire qu'il ne s'est rien
passé en cinq ans aucune mesure n'a été
prise
évidemment la thèse de l'opposition
c'est un peu le
le jeu politique donc ce matin c'est
damien abad qui s'est chargé donc
d'attaquer le gouvernement disant voyez
on aurait dû faire les choses avancent
trois ans qu'on ne fait rien sur le
sujet bon c'est un peu le problème de l
air ça fait dix ans qu'ils sont pas au
pouvoir donc ils ont l'impression depuis
dix ans il se passe rien bon en fait le
gouvernement lui bien obligé de se
défendre
donc c'est gérald darmanin qui est qui
est monté au créneau alors selon lui il
aimait cette campagne de harcèlement sur
les réseaux sociaux qui a été lancé par
un parent d un parent d'élève et bien à
conflans et bien elle n'aurait jamais dû
avoir lieu si si si seulement le conseil
constitutionnel n'avait pas censurer la
loi de laëtitia via justement se
proposait de chasse et de traquer les
contenus les messages haineux sur
internet en écoute nuisent à l'intérieur
le gouvernement essayait avec le
parlement d'avoir des armes pour lutter
contre la haine en ligne la proposition
donne à la mafia qui aurait permis
justement de faire retirer et de
poursuivre ce père de samy encore une
fois des guillemets a été censurée par
le conseil constitutionnel et vous donc
c'est la loi via n'avait pas été
censurées dire que ça va être encore en
vie un peu ce que suggère gérald
darmanin mais hélas on n'est pas obligé
d'être tout à fait convaincue un gel
d'un malin parle que de ce message d'un
parent d'être comme une fatwa zh comme
si c'était un appel au meurtre
on ne pense pas du tout du tout le cas
d'ailleurs ça mais elle pâtit lui a
porté plainte contre sur parents
d'élèves et il n'a pas porté plainte
pour incitation à la haine
même pas pour insulte simplement pour
diffamation oui on est on est très loin
de l'appel au meurtre alors laetitia
vient répondre as que sa loi aurait
empêché c'est un assassinat
lorsque c'est difficile de dire en tout
cas sur ce cas précis c'est ça paraît
improbable
alors pour terminer votre billet comment
on fait comment on fait pour lutter
contre les propagateurs de haine sur les
réseaux sociaux
eh ben c'est la solution il faudrait
pouvoir tordre le bras aux propriétaires
aux multinationales et multimilliardaire
qui sont détenteurs de ces
réseaux sociaux et qui en seront les
propriétaires mais c'est ça qui est très
compliqué d'ailleurs la loi vient
justement avait tenté de le faire
comment on fait ça on tape au
portefeuille donc on avait prévu de très
très lourd deux amendes quand un réseau
social n'enlève pas dans un délai de 24
heures un message porteur de haine mais
c'est justement ce point précis de la
loi qu a censuré le conseil
constitutionnel en dix ans et non parce
que si vous faites ça les réseaux
sociaux ont tellement peur d'être puni
par une grosse amende que ils vont dès
qu'il ya le moindre doute dès qu'un
moindre message tendancieux ils vont
être tentés de le censurer pour pas être
puni et le résultat c'est que babar
comment ça va jouer contre la liberté
d'expression donc c'est toujours le même
débat au final comment faire pour s'en
prendre aux ennemis la liberté sans s'en
prendre à la libé la liberté elle-même
merci c'est très clair on y voit
beaucoup plus clair merci stéphane a
commencé avec vous laetitia bien on va
parler de de cette nouvelle loi que vous
que vous préparez déjà vous vous êtes
d'accord parce qu'on a entendu dire que
si cette vidéo avait été retirée en
l'espèce après ce qui s'est passé il n'y
aurait pas eu de passage à l'acte ça
vous êtes d'accord avec stéphane c'est
un peu compliqué de de l'affirmer c'est
c'est compliqué mais c'est surtout très
difficile c'est très difficile d'aborder
le sujet c'est très difficile pour moi
de répondre à cette question et
permettez moi de vous dire qu'on m'a
posé cette question de nombreuses fois
depuis depuis vendredi soir et c'est un
moment humainement difficile pour moi et
sur cette vidéo le père de l'élève le
nom de l'élève de 3e samuel pâtit le
traite de voyous
il donne son propre numéro de téléphone
mais pas l'identité de sa nouvelle
patrie donne l'identité il dit où le
trouver il ya plusieurs vidéos en mai la
vidéo après justement le passage au
commissariat
c'est une vidéo où il donne les éléments
pour le trouver c'est une seconde vidéo
qui est plus agressif d'ailleurs que là
que la première
donc pour une chose il ya une forme de
texte le commanditaire un peu et on
dirait qu'il est ils étaient staff et
moi est établi que celui qui a assassiné
sauvagement sais même pas qui avait vu
cette vidéo et que c'est ça qui était
aussi cet élément déclencheur mais pour
revenir sur sur la le premier texte
il y avait deux choses il y avait cet
article premier dont on a beaucoup parlé
l'obligation de retrait en 24 heures est
contenu mais l'énorme amende sous peine
c'était un délire sous peine d'une
amende qui étaient plus faibles que
l'amande pour le retrait de contenus
excessif je tiens les plateformes ont
dit oui je ne veux pas payer
je vais ratisser très large et donc je
vais supprimer énormément de continuer
si c'est elle et le conseil
constitutionnel a dit attention aux
libertés si ce sens avait été le cas
parce que j'avais essayé mais je vous le
dis je reconnais une censure du conseil
constitutionnel c'est que ce n'était pas
suffisamment équilibré mais j'avais
essayé d'équilibrer les choses en disant
que si les plateformes s'adonnent à de
la censure est légitime donc de la sueur
censure elle encourt une sanction
jusqu'à 4% du chiffre d'affaires
donc j'avais essayé d'avoir construit
par l expert maintenant mes hommes pour
redire soit composé maintenant la sphère
de samuel bâti parce que je pense que la
réaction de le dire il y avait aussi
toute une batterie d'obligation de
moyens qui obligeait les plateformes à
faire preuve de diligence à analyser
davantage les signalements les contenus
et justement faire en sorte que l'on que
l'on sorte de cette mécanique sont
laquelle aujourd'hui si vous voulez
nuire à quelqu'un c'est très simple vous
poster ce que vous voulez vous publier
une information sur les eaux sociaux
qu'elle soit vrai qu'elle soit fausse la
viralité fera le reste
et donc ensuite cette personne aura une
cible dans le dos et c'est
malheureusement ce qui s'est produit
avec sais même pas où on va on va vous
faire quand un journal publie un article
de haine
on peut poursuivre l'auteur de l'article
et si l'auteur de l'artiste pas
identifiées le journal est responsable
c'est ça le problème c'est de trouver un
équilibre est de savoir qui est
responsable
dans quelles conditions et comment faire
en sorte que l'auteur des faits
incriminés et le porteur soir elle a
salué la présence de frédéric reste
bonsoir monsieur le député vous êtes
député les républicains du bas rhin vous
êtes aussi penché sur cette loi via et
vous avez travaillé sur sur le sujet
gilles babinet
jean louis debré dit attention dans la
loire vient ils sont considérés les
plateformes son conseil comme des
hébergeurs on demande à des hébergeurs
au fond de faire le ménage s'ils étaient
des éditeurs s'il était considérée
juridiquement comme des éditeurs
est ce qu'il pourrait être
responsabilisés par la loi oui alors je
pense qu'on a dépassé ce sujet des
éditeurs hébergeurs on parle d'un tir
statut aujourd'hui parce que c'est pas
tout à fait à des gens qui produisent du
contenu et ça n'est pas non plus
uniquement des gens qui héberge des
services dont ils n'ont pas connaissance
donc tout l'enjeu c'est d'arriver à de
trouver des dispositifs de contraintes
mais ce qu'ils sont demandeurs parce que
c'est eux sont très différents de
twitter à facebook qu'ils étaient tous
place beauvau convoqué par marlène
schiappa mettre la pression sur les
plateformes ça peut être utile ou ça
sert à rien c'est absolument
indispensable si elle et moi je pense
que on est à un tournant de la
démocratie et du fonctionnement d'une
façon générale des sociétés humaines du
fait des réseaux sociaux par exemple
l'augmentation de la dépression chez les
jeunes filles adolescentes aux etats
unis c'est plus 70% seulement cinq ans
c'est très corrélées selon les
psychiatres à l'explosion des réseaux
sociaux
et ça n'est qu'un des facteurs
qu'introduit ces réseaux là la plupart
des grands problèmes que vous rencontrez
aujourd'hui sont le fait des réseaux
sociaux alors je dis pas qu'il faut les
interdire
par exemple quand facebook quand mark
zuckerberg est venue à paris a rencontré
emmanuel macron il a dit je veux bien un
cadre il n'est pas usé de suppression de
contenus déjà non c'est de la mauvaise
foi je veux d'abord la caractéristique
vraiment la plus forte de facebook par
rapport à d'autres réseaux sociaux c'est
d'avoir mis beaucoup d'algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle qui vont
particulièrement mettre en valeur les
contenus les plus radicaux parce que ce
sont ceux qui ont la capacité de
réalisation la plus forte et c'est le
business modèle le modèle d'affaires
intrinsèque de ces plateformes de
pousser les gens à se polariser sur est
monsieur quand en droit et en droit
pénal
qu'importe aide et assistance dans la
commission d'un crime
il est condamné pour complicité
je ne vois pas pourquoi les réseaux
sociaux ou les plateformes
je suis pas un spécialiste qui héberge
des gens qui incitent à la haine au
meurtre ne serait pas condamner
quelqu'un aujourd'hui on peut circuler
la parole frédéric res est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire si vous pensez qu'on
peut responsabiliser les plateformes
comment est-ce que c'est l'état qui par
un texte de loi doit obliger ces
plateformes à supprimer des contenus où
il faut simplement comme dans le premier
texte leur faire peur non il faut
effectivement les responsabiliser et
puis on a encore entendu aujourd'hui
bruno le maire d'ailleurs disons que des
plateformes sur internet doivent être
responsabilisés
comment fait donc il ya un certain
nombre de mesures et nous ne sommes pas
seuls sur ce sujet là c'est à dire c'est
une question qu'on se pose travers le
monde entier donc un titre personnel moi
je pense que il faut en discuter au
moins au niveau européen parce que là
quelqu'un d'ailleurs en ce moment c'est
ce qui est le cas à l'union européenne
on y va on a commencé en 2010 est
d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
préconisations et moi je suis très
content de pouvoir vous parler un petit
peu ce soir de ce qui se passe au
conseil de l'europe
parce que le conseil d'europe qui est
très méconnue a beaucoup travaillé sur
ces sujets là sur ce sujet donc des
droits de l'homme qui sait ce qu'on fait
quelles mesures concrètes
pour réussir à ce que cette haine en
ligne déjà la haine en ligne parce
qu'aujourd'hui il faut être très clair
il ya des lois déjà vous faites un appel
au meurtre
tout ça est retirée immédiatement çà çà
çà çà çà se fait rapidement vous faites
de l'incitation à la haine raciale
normalement il ya des signalements et ça
se sait retirer on sait bien seul c'est
bien ça le problème
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure lorsque
mark zuckerberg est venue à paris moi
j'ai rencontré à cette occasion marc
zuckerberg
il veut un cadre mais il veut fixer le
cadre il ne veut pas être
responsabilisés c'est ça le problème des
plateformes c'est qu'elles veulent fixer
leurs propres règles et ne pas être
sanctionné si jamais elle ne respecte
pas ces règles
et aujourd'hui la modération elle se
fait par les plateformes selon leur bon
vouloir et je vois supprimer les comptes
n'est celle forcément les plateformes
depuis 2000 doit pas le faire depuis
récupéré 1004 raison ce droit c'est dans
notre loi de retirer des contenus et
donc elles retirent mais retire ce
qu'elles veulent comme elles veulent
quand elles veulent vous allez sur une
plateforme comme facebook
vous n'allez pas avoir par exemple les
dommages qui sont à parler patois
refaites le patois numérique
je parle d'une fatwa ou sont ce voile à
plein du terme ou mais vous faites un
appel au meurtre
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est un
signalement qui aujourd'hui sur ces
plateformes toute une armada de juristes
d'avocats avec l'intelligence
artificielle on arrive à cerner et on
essaie de l'enlever et facebook
aujourd'hui 10 à 99 5% il enlève les
contenus illicites et ne sent que
quelqu'un même les signaler à l'embellie
des statistiques aussi important car
cette frontière l'incitation à la haine
les propos haineux enfin d'abord cette
frontière extrêmement poreuse et je
crois que c'est les cas où quelqu'un dit
je vais assassiner intel sont
extrêmement rares et je pense que on a
une très très grande catégorie cas qui
sont extrêmement problématique sur
lequel on ne s'est pas posé facilement
un diagnostique et puis au delà de saint
vous avez un enjeu qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que cette modération
elle est quasiment invisible c'est à
dire que si chacun d'entre nous on poste
un article et l'algorithme décide de
mettre l'un d'entre eux plus en avant
que les autres eh bien vous ne voyez pas
vous n'avez pas l'impression qu'il ya le
travail d'un algorithme modération
concrètement ce sont 12 à ressemble à
quoi c'est comment ça se passe c'est
tout à fait automatique c'est à dire que
on va mettre une note
on va décider que laëtitia via par
exemple ces contenus sont généralement
plus populaire que les autres et donc on
va subrepticement les mettre en avant
de cette façon là ils ont créé ce
faisant alors je vous accuse en rien des
bulles d'enfermement cirque on se rend
compte que telle personne est un bon
public pour tel type de contenu que
telle autre personne crée ce type de
compagnies l'enfermer dans des communes
et des gens qui pensent pas cibler ce
que je voudrais ce sur quoi je voudrais
insister et d'ailleurs je voudrais
répondre à votre point c'est que c'est
extrêmement subtil c'est à dire que les
gens ne se rendent pas compte ils ne se
rendent pas compte ils ont l'impression
qu'ils sont face à une hétérogénéité de
point de vue alors que en réalité ils
sont dans une bulle où il ne voit
absolument que la motion qui doit
attendait qui doit malama via contrôlé
alors doit être le contrôleur ce sont
les plateformes ce sont les plateformes
qui ont l'outil ce sont les plateformes
qui ont accès au contenu ce sont celles
qui créent aussi cette viralité autour
de ces publications
aujourd'hui
les la modération se fait soit sur la
base de des plateformes qui elle-même
détecte des contenus et elles le font de
plus en plus et je vous dis moi ça me
gêne d'ailleurs parce que ça veut dire
qu'elles suppriment des contenus même
avant même qu'il ne soit publié
et donc on ne sait pas de quoi il s'agit
ça peut être des contenus les plus les
plus dangereux possible et dans ce cas
là je pense qu'on devrait être informés
que les autorités devraient être
informés ou ça peut être mais qui suffit
permettez-moi de le dire une perte de
200 pour que ce soit supprimée mais dont
on n'arrive pas à faire la distinction
entre les deux ce que je propose et
c'est un élément extrêmement important
c'est que les plateformes elle met des
moyens des moyens qui soit à la fois des
moyens financiers humains et
technologiques dans la plateforme dans
leur modération qui soit proportionnelle
à l'activité de la plateforme
comment on va les obliger comment
voulait contrer la loi par la loi et
avec la supervision ensuite d'un
régulateur qui va aller voir si regard
du volume de l'activité de ceux d'une
plateforme
il ya suffisamment de moyens dédiés à la
modération
ça peut marcher je suis pas un
spécialiste mais les pas les plateformes
appartiennent à des groupes pour des
gens corps bien quand on publie sur une
plateforme une incitation au meurtre
peut-être qu'on ne trouvera pas la
personne qui a incité mais là pas de
forme et responsable et là on dit c'est
pas nous c'est les algorithmes non je
comprends et je comprends les sondages
ne sont pas conduire pas par
l'informatique
il ya un moment nous sommes dans une
société humaine il ya des hommes il ya
les gens je cherche absolument pas à
dissoudre la responsabilité des
plateformes que je trouve absolument
mais il ya des grands procès mais
d'abord je vais vous dire quelque chose
si quelqu un appel au meurtre il peut le
faire de façon extrêmement détourné
de tout un tas de façons et puis
l'interprétation vous pouvez faire si je
dis par exemple lui je vais le décalque
et ça peut être quelque chose qui est au
figuré où ça peut être ça veut dire je
vais le descendre et ces enjeux là vous
n'allez pas les traiter de façon simple
ce que vous pouvez traiter rapidement
c'est changer le modèle d'affaires des
plateformes et leur dire il faut
absolument arrêter la polarisation et là
on doit faire des stress tests et audits
on doit s'assurer que elles rétablissent
je dirais des débats normaux aujourd'hui
le modèle des plateformes c'est
d'opposer les uns contre les autres et
d'éviter un taiwo n'diaye un débat
intelligent qui secret et vous rendez
pas compte mais c'est ça qui construit
le problème c'est que c'est ça qui à la
fin les gens font n'importe quoi ne
répondait pas aux faux solution va
peut-être dire de moi là dessus c'est à
dire des titres via bien parler d'un
régulateur au conseil de l'europe
nous avons proposé à ce que les pays
mettent en place une sorte d'institution
qu'on appelle le nombre de semaines
c'est à dire une sorte de médiateur qui
pourrait réagir très vite qui n'est pas
forcément un juge et qui pourrait servir
avec les plateformes leur intérêt dans
la mesure est une institution comme ça
elle a un coût des signalements c'est
notamment mais pharos c'est à travailler
avec la police mais on pourrait voir ça
de manière beaucoup plus globale et
beaucoup de général et à partir de ce
moment ce coup tu devrais être pris en
charge par les plateformes et elle même
et il faudrait évidemment que ces
plateformes y trouvent leur intérêt et
que pour y trouver leur intérêt
il faut que derrière par exemple ils
puissent éviter des poursuites pénales
ou des choses comme ça s'ils ont suivi
l'intérêt de ce reboot man il ya
certains pays on essaie d'avancer dans
cette direction par exemple aux pays bas
par exemple à yb a été fait à gergy jeu
pour raconter une petite anecdote qui va
répondre deux préoccupations évoquées
par jean louis debré identifiées donc
les auteurs de ces contenus pouvoir les
poursuivre et puis éventuellement pourra
poursuivre les plateformes
lors de mes auditions sur cette
proposition de loi moi j'ai noté que les
plateformes
elle avait une coopération aléatoire
lorsqu'il s'agit d' s'agissait de donner
les éléments d'identification de leurs
utilisateurs
c'est une obligation qui sont dans la
loi sur certains contenus
elle donne et puis d'autres faut faire
des réquisitions encore encore et aucune
réponse
donc j'ai reçu toutes les plateformes et
je leur ai dit on va faire quelque chose
on va on va dire vous avez une
obligation de répondre à toutes les
réquisitions judiciaires
et si vous ne le faites pas c'est votre
responsable en france qui sera
responsable pénalement je peux vous dire
qu'il ya eu une vraie levée de boucliers
de la mare des plateformes à ce moment
là dès lors qu'on parle de la
responsabilité
il n'y a plus personne on ne veut pas
toucher au financement de ces
plateformes ci a trois ou quatre fois on
a fait rappeler à l'ordre une plate
forme parce qu'elles vivent comment
elles vivent et et d'un concurrent des
uns et des autres et elles gagnent
beaucoup d'argent bien aimé on ne veut
pas toucher au financement de ces
plateformes et si aussi demain pas
répondu à aux agents du show eh bien on
fait en sorte qu'elle ne veut plus se
dit finaliser ou non la taxe financière
on allait lui très clairement d'abord
dans leur gpd vous avez repris ce
principe d'ailleurs il ya l'idée d'avoir
une taxation de 4% protection des
données et vous avez repris ce principe
de 4% ce qu'on a vu c'est que pour le
moment lorsque notamment facebook a été
puni d'une amende aux états unis en
particulier et bien le cours en bourse
montait parce que la montre était juré
jugé suffisamment faible pour n'avoir
pas d'incidence sur les affaires ils ont
une avance de 5 milliards de dollars
quand même et le jour même où la demande
a été prononcé leur cours en bourse a
augmenté
voilà donc si vous voulez moi je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous on doit
taper au portefeuille fort et je pense
qu'il faudrait peut-être aller au-delà
des 4 % parce que semble-t-il c'est pas
forcément suffisant avoir une assiette
qui soit globale évidemment mais même ça
je ne suis pas sûr que ce soit essayons
nécessairement subir essayé depuis ce
niveau là
les français qui nous regardent se
disent bon la première loi à l'eau à
vienne n'est pas passé qu'est ce que
vous allez proposer très concrètement
par l'étape de portefeuille j'ai
présenté plusieurs solutions
gouvernement puisqu'il ya eu une censure
du conseil constitutionnel donc faut
être très très précautionneux je ne vais
plus sur les obligations de retrait je
pense que ça a cristallisé trop de
tension et que c'est un sujet trop
sensible on regarde notre liberté
d'expression
en revanche les plateformes doivent être
diligente investissements moyens humains
moyens financiers et moyens techniques
un traitement approprié des signalements
un examen approprié de l'ensemble des
contenus de la transparence
aujourd'hui je suis incapable de vous
dire combien de modérateur chez twitter
après trois ans sur le sujet je ne sais
même pas où ils sont physiquement c'est
hallucinant ça et donc tout cela sous la
supervision du régulateur qui pourra les
sanctionner jusqu'à 4% du chiffre
d'affaires y compris celles ne collabore
pas avec la la on va voir ce que ça va
donner un arbre à nocolas oublier c'est
le mot de responsabilité hélas les
plates formes ne sont plus responsables
et bien glauques de venir il ya un débat
j'aurais voulu mais on n'a pas le temps
d'en parler aux états unis sur la
fermeture de facebook
il existe en quelques secondes oui oui
tout à fait il est très vaste et je
pense qu'il prend beaucoup d'ampleur et
je dire on est un petit peu retors là
dessus j'en profite pour vous parler de
ce rapport interne en péril jeune
publié à simon pegg et quitterait maman
du débat que nous devons avoir un peu de
publicité ça fait pas de mal merci à
tous merci beaucoup jean-luc devrait
d'abord été le grand témoin de cette
émission très belle soirée à demain
[Musique]